bonjour claude quel est véritablement
selon vous le noeud du problème dans ces
tensions diplomatiques entre alger et
rabat et puis évidemment première
question est ce que cette accusation ou
semble plausible
écoutez comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure le communiqué de la présidence
de la république algérienne hier soir a
accusé le maroc de fomenter
régulièrement des actes hostiles
incessants deal communiqué et a par
conséquent
amener l'algérie à intensifier les
contrôles à la frontière cela dit cette
frontière elle est fermée depuis 25 ans
l'algérie accuse en réalité le mouvement
pour l'autodétermination de la kabylie
basé à paris
aussi le mouvement rachad islamistes qui
lui est basé à londres d'être à
l'origine des incendies soutenus par des
puissances étrangères dont bien entendu
selon l'algérie le maroc et israël donc
on voit bien là aussi la critique du
rapprochement entre le baroque qu'israël
qui apparaît en filigrane
il y à un mois l'algérie avait pris une
mesure importante qui était le rappel de
son ambassadeur à rabat pour protester
contre le fait que dans une réunion d du
mouvement des non alignés à à l'onu que
les diplomates marocains avaient diffusé
note dans laquelle il est indiqué que
bien entendu le peuple kabyle avait
droit à l'autodétermination alors ça
c'est évidemment le chiffon rouge pour
le gouvernement algérien et il avait
pris cette mesure de rappel de son
ambassadeur est une mesure très forte
surtout entre ces deux pays voisins donc
la situation
continue de se dégrader c'est peut-être
aussi pour donner le change à la
population devant les difficultés à
gérer la crise du que vide vous avez
parlé de tunisie mais c'est vrai aussi
dans les autres pays du maghreb et puis
ces incendies qui font rage tout autour
de la méditerranée pas seulement pas
seulement
en algérie mais aussi mais aussi au
maroc mais aussi sur la rive nord en
grèce en espagne en italie en france
d'ailleurs et effectivement sans qu'il
soit nécessaire d'accuser le voisin
d'être à l'origine de cette séance en
incendie qui sont parfois l'origine
criminelle mais pas toujours avec des
motivations politiques alors vous avez
hockey à l'instant les frontières entre
l'algérie et le maroc qui sont fermés
depuis plus d'un quart de siècle le roi
mohamed 6 s'est prononcé en faveur d'une
réouverture à ce que cela vous paraît
réaliste et si tel était le cas est ce
que vous pensez que cela constituerait
une réelle amorce d'un réchauffement des
relations entre les deux états
c'est sûrement un objectif à poursuivre
parce que il s'agit de deux pays voisins
qui ont beaucoup de choses en commun et
qui naturellement devrait développer
leurs échanges
cela dit c'est peu prévisible que ça
arrive à très court terme parce que au
sud le maroc a construit un mur entre la
partie du sahara occidental qui contrôle
et l'algérie
de façon à
éviter les attaques dit il de la part de
du mouvement des sahraouis et on voit
bien que le maroc se protège de toute
forme d'incursions algérienne donc tout
ça dépend en fait de l'évolution du
conflit à propos du sahara occidental à
part ça qu'est-ce qui pourrait selon
vous participez à un apaisement de ses
relations tendues entre alger et rabat
on a essayé beaucoup de choses
périodiquement les gouvernements
marocain et algérien vont essayer
d'aboutir par des négociations
bilatérales
amélioration des rapports des échanges
d'étudiants
des accords économiques
on a aussi étudié on a aussi essayé la
formule de style à terral puisque en
2008 la france avait pris l'initiative
de l'union pour la méditerranée qui
réunissait tous les pays riverains de la
méditerranée plus tous les pays de
l'union européenne et l'idée à l'époque
était de promouvoir des projets concrets
par exemple la dépollution des ports par
exemple l'interconnexion des routes par
exemple la construction de chemins de
fer pour relier les différents pays du
pourtour méditerranéen et notamment les
pays du maghreb entre eux parce que les
échanges ça veut dire bien entendu une
interconnexion l'interconnexion des
routes d'une interconnexion des chemins
de fer et puis peut-être aussi
d'équipements comme l'électricité ou
comme l'eau puisque on s'aperçoit que
aujourd'hui l'algérie manque cruellement
que d'eau par conséquent c'est sans
doute sur ces sujets concrets qu'il
faudrait travailler plus que sur les
sujets proprement politique merci
beaucoup pour votre éclairage claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales à éditorialistes cercles
france